hey welcome to the Reuben report i'm
dave rubin according to the paperwork
I've got fred Karger and brett erlich
with me here we go all right turkey you
may have heard that something's going
down in Turkey although the mainstream
media is kind of dropped the ball on
this if you are a fan of The Young Turks
jank is doing a nuanced and effective
job explaining what's going on so I want
to talk about it in a kind of Broadway
basically a bunch of protesters were at
gezi Park the Turkish government was
building another mall they've been
building a ton of malls partly because
the economy is good and people want to
shop but there's no green space in
Turkey people want parks they're not
happy this has turned into riots and
protests and all kinds of stuff but we
are not really hearing about it here in
America which is a little bizarre
because we heard about Egypt we heard
about Libya and what's going on this is
our big Alli Obama called the Turkish
Prime Minister hurry owed on his his
best friend in the Middle East so
something is amiss Fred what's going on
in Turkey and why are we hearing about
it that's where I want to start on this
I think there's just it's a sleeper
problem right now and I mean if I were
in Turkey I be demonstrating you can't
even get a turkey sandwich and Turkey
you were said earlier you gotta go to
Greece why can't you get their biggest I
don't know I looked all over because I
wanted a photo when i was there of me
eating a turkey sandwich but it's it's
it's what's going on all over the Middle
East right now and it's a secular
government it's a secular Prime Minister
and there are a lot of religious
factions there and I think it's a lot of
other reasons I don't think it's
necessarily what what the one issue is
for more green space I think he's got
some serious problems and we could see
another downfall of another regime yeah
so before we get into the specifics of
what's going on there what do you think
of the media coverage as a media guy it
seems very bizarre to me that we're
seeing like 30 seconds on CNN and then
you know oj simpson again yeah some lame
Syria because it was the Arab Spring and
we got behind everyone who sprung up at
that point and it was very simple and we
just ran the gamut there was that you
know just northern Africa and we just
dealt with and then it got to Syria and
suddenly it was complicated right and
now everyone's looking at it
oh god I'm sure I first of all Syria
involves a lot of homework then I'm just
I know this all the photos of Turkey
look like photos from occupy Los Angeles
but I'm sure if I just peel it back it's
gonna be too messy let's get out of it
yeah I actually think you're totally
right on this that Syria has caused us
because we don't know who the good guys
are there we don't know who the bad guys
are everybody's killing everybody and I
think we sort of have this fatigue we're
having like Arab Spring fatigue where
it's like oh this is just a repeat we
could just watch the footage from you
know from Cairo so what is our
responsibility in the world when this
stuff goes on because there's definitely
like this thing in the United States
right now like we can't get involved in
anything and I'm not saying we should be
involved in Turkey and it's you know
it's not nearly as bad as the other ones
especially Syria but what is our
responsibility when we're broke and
people don't want us all over the world
and all that well Syria is the problem
and that is a hot spot and their
factions like John McCain who want us to
go in there and take sides on the rebel
arm the rebels read the Taliban and so
we're we've got a problem in that area
and of course Israel's gone in and take
it out somewhat what they believe are
some problem areas that are fueling
their enemies through Iran yeah and when
you look at the map of Syria it's
surrounded by Lebanon and Iraq and Iran
where we've got some serious Geographic
problems there we need to watch it
carefully but I don't think we need to
get into that area and it in expose our
troops because of a civil war that's
going on there but Assad has has got to
go yeah is part of the problem that
serious such a freaking mess that we
can't do anything in turkey because we
sort of need the the government there
because that we are friendly enough with
them that we can have Turkey going down
while Syria's going down I mean it's
just on down this turkeys is is is a
different beast than all the rest of the
Arab Spring nations because turkey yet
turkeys secular in you know it is it is
more than you know 50 purse it's mostly
Muslim yeah so it's like this weird you
ever see the movie there the TV show
sliders yes Jerry O'Connell
we would like or like cool yes like he
would like slide into a different
dimension where most of the stuff was
the same and there was like one key
difference that's what turkey is like mo
you look at it it looks like San
Francisco yeah but like something like
you then it all has like Roman letters
but like then you see like the little
you know diera says those two dots over
the over the over some leather yeah
you're just like wait a minute that's
not that's not san francisco right um
but i think what we can glean from it is
is to understand that right now it is it
is in the nascent stages of something
that that could get big but right now
it's pretty much localized to a specific
parks in certain cities there's some
fantastic hashtags like resistant ball
yeah that's a good at something we can
glean right um but even if funny that it
takes a hashtag to get us involved
because sure because truly I mean the
Turkish Prime Minister said this week
that the biggest problem here is Twitter
not as I do with the government but
Twitter is causing unrest you know top
cause like when we think about like a
nation somewhere in like a Muslim zone
yeah we think of like uh well the big
decision is do how much power do we give
a dictator because you know otherwise
there's a bunch of like really crappy
factions that would all kill each other
maybe it needs like someone to be just a
jerk yeah and kind you know a little bit
bit bigger of a jerk but like you know
turkeys always on the on the the cusp of
being led into like these really big
awesome clubs that that mostly western
nations are led into right there in NATO
and they do behave in a mostly
democratic way yeah and yet they're not
fully democratic cuz they're in a pretty
crappy part of the world yeah I was in I
was in Turkey a couple years ago and I
was on a tour I'm a tourist not a travel
on the doors yes um and I was finding me
a fact-finding mission like where is an
RVs um cuz I'm tired of your food but no
this guy was like you know we're really
close to get it being led into the EU
except for like you know the genocide
thing it's a little testy still and he
was like laughing he's like that turkey
we've got we got problems yeah what do
you
alright final thought on this though the
part that seems fascinating to me is
that we don't it seems very obvious to
me that America doesn't want anything to
do with that part of the world anymore
but if we if we pull out we have no
money and all that stuff and we don't
want our troops getting killed all
legitimate reasons if we don't do
anything good is there anyone left like
I feel like the world will just go to
hell in a handbasket and maybe that's
just the way it's kind of going to
because no one else is going to jump in
and ever try to try to do something good
right if I mean if the US doesn't do it
is anyone gonna do it well I like but
the Secretary of State John Kerry is
doing right now which is trying to
negotiate with Assad and to get a some
peace there James Baker who was this
Secretary of State under george HW bush
he went to Syria 23 times to try and get
Assads father to go to the madrid peace
talks and that's what we really need
keep going back he was persistent he
finally got Assad on that twenty third
trip to go to Madrid for the peace talks
so we need to negotiate we don't need to
just go in there and arm our arm the
rebels and I think that's a better
solution right we're working on it right
they want armed rebels we don't know who
the rebels are I also saw that this week
now France is saying they're absolutely
was chemical weapons in Syria and it's
like well now what do we do like why is
it that we care more about how people
get killed whether it's by regular
weapons or chemical weapons then how
many cuz 80,000 seems like yeah people
does it's a diplomacy word cloud because
we know that chemical weapons are a bad
thing that sounds man and we went in
because we were looking for them in Iraq
if we actually find them something must
be major right yeah and Smee like yeah
and right now in the grand scheme of
things like relations with Turkey are
touchy anyway because recently there was
that run-in with the Israel and Turkey
and we made turkey and enemy and we need
them because they're a foothold in that
area I would think of you know this is
terrible what I'm about to say but Syria
is an Africa major and turkey is in Asia
Minor so okay all right well anyone on
CNN wolf if you want to air this clip to
explain some of this stuff that seems to
have gone over your head you have full
rights to it I'm happy to lend it to you
you